I am the only American,
probably the only person in the world,
who has been banned by a federal court
from decorating for Christmas.
I love Christmas more than life itself.
Christmas tree time, let's go!
He doesn't know when to stop.
Some people call me "Mr. Christmas."
Accurate.
-This is the one.
-Honey, it's too big for the dining room.
We gotta get a bigger house.
Jeremy Morris said that he was
going to be purchasing a home
in our subdivision.
Jeremy asked a ton of questions,
seemed kinda weird.
This house, it's perfect
for hosting this Christmas show.
What is this guy up to?
This Christmas show,
five thousand people...
We need to make it bigger.
Noise, the traffic...
The people in this neighborhood
didn't want it.
These neighbors threw a rock:
the threat of a lawsuit.
"Your planned event is not permitted."
It's at that point that I decided
I'm going ahead with the show.
What's going on here is not religious.
Penguins.
It was Frosty the Snowman
and hot chocolate...
It was always his way or no way.
At the end of the day,
is all this really worth it?
Yes.
Nobody is gonna stop me.
It's this constant loop of crazy.
The thirty-five-person choir,
the camel...
Intimidation, bully tactics...
If people think I'm crazy,
they don't know what I'm gonna do next.
You can always subpoena the camel.
He is one hundred percent calculated.
We'll be appealing to the Supreme Court.
Now that's nuts.
We have great neighbors,
pitted against one person.
My neighbors are essentially terrorists.
I wanted to become the guy
who saved Christmas.
Oh, you didn't get a permit.
This is a miracle.
You don't get permits for miracles.